welcome to the very last episode of this
completely free archicad course what's
going on team my name is David tomage
I'm a registered architect here in
Western Australia and today I'm sharing
with you how you can export all of this
information and present it to the world
last time we left off with our door and
window schedule now it's time to put
everything into perspective and Export
it ready to go if we jump across to our
layout book up the top you'll see we
have a series of pages and folders we
also have our Master templates down
below as well for perhaps of this I'm
simply just going to open our design
development folder which is going to
show you a series of different pages so
if I double click on our drawing list
for example it'll indicate all the pages
in this drawing list it'll tell you some
instructional information
generically speaking of what it would
like you to see on this page it is
completely up to you guys how and what
you place on these Pages personally I
probably wouldn't put a satellite but
heck up to everybody individually of
course you have the generic title block
down the bottom as well which defines
all of the information required on an
architectural documentation package now
everything you see with a little hashtag
sign certifier hashtag civil engineer if
we go into file info project info you'll
see there is a bunch of options that we
can add or deduct from so I've already
put the project name as free YouTube
course and it will populate all of that
information but if we go to certify down
below and we go
that guy and mechanical engineer we go
one man band press ok
you'll see it automatically changes all
that information before you export any
of these documents you obviously want to
go through all of this information cross
check make sure it is correct and make
sure that the information is up to date
at all times here you'll see replace
with your logo and can't actually do
anything you can't double click on it
you can't drag and drop and that's
because this is the actual template
Master file which is down here if we
want to find out what we're using we are
right click layout settings and we see
we're using the A1 landscape title block
if you click on that you can change the
title block to Different Page sizes as
well so if you didn't want an A1 page
you could change it and you can also
change the numbering automatically we
won't dive too far into that I did make
a separate video entirely on layouts and
title blocks so if you wish to use that
you can but if we come down to our
Master double click on our A1 landscape
title block you can see we can now click
on everything in the title block this is
part of a source and has been dragged
and dropped in so right click open
source View and it will take you
directly to that information so if we
wanted to replace that logo drag and
drop outs in there we absolutely could
no problems whatsoever going back to our
drawing list and working our way through
you'll see now if you're new to arcad
you're probably also new to residential
design as a whole if you are Luis
ferocio's graphic guide to residential
design is an excellent ebook there is a
link down below but it basically
showcases you all the steps all the
logic and all the reasons why every
architect around the world makes logical
and rational decisions about their
designs all the units inside are both in
metric and Imperial to cater to the
entire world Lewis has done an amazing
job and deserves full credit on this
ebook hence why I'm sharing this
resource with you guys today a01 site
survey has no information on it because
we don't have a site survey available to
us so we could either delete that page
omit it or do whatever we wish a02
automatically has the information on our
site plan now this site plan is at a one
to 200 scale whereas personally I prefer
it as a one to 100 scale so if we double
click on our site plan
let's change this to 1 to 100 you'll see
a lot more information context become
available we can then change a few of
our settings down below so it goes into
black and white it has site plan no
filters applied we can go settings we
can go get current window view and press
OK we would then obviously go in and add
all of our extra information our
annotations our Dimensions our angles
etc etc all relatively self-explanatory
so for instance Dimension click once
click twice right click OK drag it out
to where you want and the dimension is
created that sort of stuff for the basic
documentation I won't need to go into it
is self-explanatory literally just go
through them one by one click them try
it out there is nothing special now if
we go back to our A2 site plan that will
automatically update to 1 to 100 scale
and it's slightly too big over the page
so what I'm going to do is command d
drop it down ever so slightly click on
the edges reduce the size and place it
in the center of the page because that's
just how I personally like it it's up to
you guys how you place everything how
you define it on the page and what you
put on each everything here is simply a
guide now if you are unsure of what goes
on every single page and what
information is required if you jump onto
davidtomage.com there's a link down in
the description for this as well jump
into products go to our all in one
checklist so enter into that product and
basically this will provide you with a
series of checklist items
258 checklist items in total defining
exactly what needs to be on every page
so there's a quick Glimpse in to this
checklist I have not shown these before
I try to avoid showing this information
because obviously you have to pay for it
however this is the complete one out of
two pages for sketch design and this is
the first of 10 10 pages for
construction drawings basically you need
to have all of this information on each
individual plan so we have our site plan
one to two hundred minimum scale do you
have a North Point scale bar title block
are all of your external walls columns
concrete deckings
Etc annotated and detailed if they're
not you have to go through this
checklist to find out so once they're
done you simply tick all of the boxes
the PDF is incredibly reactive I have
detailed this as a black document
because I believe you should not have to
print these out you should be able to
use it digitally time and time and time
again and let's save the planet wherever
we can goes so I've used it as a
negative dock think before you print and
simply use it as a digital document as
you require again the link is in the
description if you want to grab this to
make sure you know everything that needs
to go on each individual page continuing
to work through all of the pages the
process is exact the same and quite
familiar if we click through the pages
you'll see elements start popping up in
the wrong directions so all you need to
do is drag the edges correct the
information where you need it to be
drag and drop exactly where you'd like
it to be in that page and continue
moving on if for any instance you get to
let's say elevations and information is
missing or you'd like to have something
extra on this page all you have to do is
come back to your view map find the
information that you're trying to look
for so let's say we want to show our
ground floor here for whatever reason
doesn't really matter all you have to do
is drag drop and it will include the
ground floor plan into that page then
you simply adjust all of the information
drag it to where you need to be and you
have that ground floor showing us the
elevations or whatever you might need I
don't need that simply delete it but
that is how you would work around
information missing on the architectural
plans now there's also a number of ways
to export this PDF the simplest way is
to Simply go into this drop down menu go
show organizer
let's stretch this out ever so slightly
come across to our publishing set and
you can do it in a number of ways you
can export to a PDF you can batch render
folder structure you can also export
dwgs here as well in this instance we
could simply drag the whole thing across
right click publisher properties Define
the path let's just save that to our
desktop
press OK press ok
and we can either merge it to one PDF or
export it as multiple PDFs for me it's
easy to merge as one PDF hit the publish
button let it do its thing it may take a
while depending on how many pages you
have and how much information is there
and then go to your desktop double click
the PDF and you'll see everything has
exported
as you have placed it now obviously I
haven't gone through and detailed any of
this put anything in the correct places
so you will have to do that but all the
information that you will need is here
and ready to go anyway team that's all
from me thank you so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed the video if you did
make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below and like always I'll
see you next Monday